the link reader is a powerful tool for
language learners
make sure to take advantage of the
settings and personalize your reader
here's how i personalized mine
i don't want to turn my blue words
yellow when i click away from them or
make them known when i page
so i uncheck these settings
that way when i initially listen to the
audio and read through my lesson the
blue words won't change
once i'm ready to deal with my blue
words i can turn these settings back on
i also change the font and page size to
the way i like it
another way to get more out of link is
by tagging words and phrases
i can use the tag adjective or future
for the verb tense for example
how you tag is up to you
but you can start to tag based on which
vocabulary you want to focus on or are
having trouble with
once links are tagged i can review them
at any time in the vocabulary section
i just choose the tag or tags and up
comes the list of tagged terms which i
can then review
it's a good idea to tag words but also
phrases that encompass the concept you
are focusing on
if at any time i have a question about a
word or phrase in the lesson i just
click ask a tutor here and post my
question
i'll then be notified when a tutor gets
back to me
finally it's a great idea to take the
time to learn the keyboard shortcuts
i access them here and click show more
to see the full list
everyone has a preferred way of using
the reader and knowing the keyboard
shortcuts gives me the chance to figure
out mine
there are some special keys that help me
do some special tasks but mostly it's
the standard functions that are
convenient
for example i use the up down keys to
select different translations or known
and ignore
then right arrow to choose the current
selection and move on to the next
highlighted word
next time you're in the link reader
explore the different ways you can make
it work for you happy linking